M. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA ATKINS BAIT
BACKER PORCHES BRADFORD COME BY
ADAM CORTEZ THE- DALLY DODD
YOU'RE AWESOME EGGMAN GLAZER
GONZALEZ ROVE HURTS FOR WEST SO
HER TADO JONES CAM WALKER
LAYERED LEYVA THE MON WIRE
MELINDA'S MEN NEWMAN NIELSEN A
SHOW OF VOGUE PAN FORTUNE TINO.
RALPH RUBIO SKINNER STERN AMBERG
WHITE HOUSE SKI WINNER WELL.
MEMBERS OF A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
GOOD MORNING WHAT OUR MEMBERS
AND OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL.
AND IN THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE.
WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING BY SENATOR LABOR AFTER
WHICH WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU TO
REMAIN STANDING AND WILL BE LED
IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG BY SENATOR CALM WATER
SOONER OR LATER. THANK YOU MR
PRSIDENT GOOD MORNING MEMBERS.
EVERY NEW ALL GOD OF MANY NAMES
AND ONE TRANSFORMING AND
ABUNDANT LOVE. WE TURN THIS
MONTH IN OUR NATION'S LIFE TO
REFLECT ON THE STORIES THE
HERITAGE. AND THE STRUGGLES OF
WOMEN THROUGHOUT THE AGES. WE
SEEK TO LEARN FROM ALL VOICES
THAT HAVE BEEN LEFT UNHEARD.
MAYBE PAUSE BEFORE THE SILENCE
OF THE AGES. FIND OUT WHO HAS
BEEN LEFT OUT AND CRAFT NEW WAYS
OF INCLUSION. FOR EVERY WEEK AND
EVERY MONTH MAY THE SPIRITUAL
PRACTICE. BRING OUT THE VOICES
OF ALL THOSE STRUGGLING. AND ALL
OF THOSE LEFT APART. MAY WE GO
OF OUR ASSUMPTIONS AND COLD
COMFORTS OF WHAT IS THE NORMAL
TO LIVE BY. UNLESS IT BE A
STANDARD THAT IS ROOTED IN
COMPASSION AND INCLUSIVITY AND
DIVERSITY. MAY THIS MONTH OF
REFLECTION TEACH US TO SEARCH
FOR THOSE STORIES THAT ARE
DIFFERENT FROM OUR OWN. MOTHER
OF POSSIBILITIES IN THE FINDING
MAY BECOME TO KNOW OURSELVES
CHANGED RENEWED WHERE WE ARE DRY
HOPEFUL WHERE WE ARE LOST AN
OPEN WHERE WE ARE SHOT. AMEN
COURTESY OF REVEREND JUDE GEIGER.
OKAY. IT IS ALL. THANK YOU
MEMBERS BEFORE WE BEGIN WE WANT
TO RECOGNIZE SOME GUESTS IN THE
GALLERY WE HAVE LEADERSHIP
MORGAN HILL SO THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US GIVEN THE SENATE
WELCOME ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
LAYER THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE. MEMBERS WE'RE GOING
TO GET GOING MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE GAME READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEM RAT. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BEING DOING READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES ARE
THERE ANY AT THIS TIME NO.
MEMBERS NOW WE'RE MOVING TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
. WE HAVE SECOND READING FILE
ITEM ONE SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
EIGHTY SIX. THANK YOU MOVING OUT
TO UNFINISHED BUSINESS ITEM TO
SENATOR MCGUIRE. MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION EIGHTY TWO BY SENATOR
ATKINS RELATIVE TO THE ADOPTION
OF A JOINT RULES OF THE SENATE
AND ASSEMBLY FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO REGULAR
SESSION. SOONER MAGOR THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND HAPPY SAINT
PATRICK'S DAY MISTER PRESIDENT-
S. C. R. EIGHTY TWO IS BACK FROM
THE ASSEMBLY FOR CONCURRENCE IT
IS TOO TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS THAT
THE PRO TEN WOULD LIKE THE BODY
YOU KNOW ABOUT. THESE AMENDMENTS
ARE MADE ME SIMPLY THE NAME IS
CLARIFIED THAT THE CHANGE TO
AUTHORIZING COMMITTEE MEETINGS
IN THE- STREET BUILDING ALSO
APPLIES TO CONFERENCE COMMITTEES
NUMBER TWO THEY ALSO CLARIFIED
THAT BILLS WOULD JOIN AUTHORS
FROM BOTH HOUSES CAN'T BE USED
TO CIRCUMVENT BILL LIMITS BY
CLARIFYING THAT A MEMBER OF THE
OTHER HOUSE THE ONLY BE JOIN
AUTHOR AND CANNOT BE A LEAD
AUTHOR WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I VOTE ON CONCURRENCE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE SENATOR NELSON. THIS
PRESENT LET INJURED ON THE
SENATE WITH ALL RESPECT. TO OUR
PRO TEM. THESE REMARKS HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE PROGRAM.
BUT WITH THE RELATIVE AUTHORITY
AND POWERS AND TRADITIONS OF THE
SENATE SENATOR NELSON YOU I'LL
STICK TO THE AMENDMENTS I URGE A
NO VOTE. THANK YOU FOR ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. SENIOR NO FURTHER
MICROPHONES SENATOR MCGUIRE
WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE BUT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON FILE ITEM TO. ALAN
ARCHULETA FIVE ATKINS. BASED NO
BACKER HI FORGES. BRADFORD I
COME BEARING FIVE OR TEN THIRTY
FIVE DOLLY. NO DOG I YOU'RE
AWESOME I ADMIN I GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE I GROW. NO HERTZBERG
I WESSEL I HER TADO I JONES. NO
CAN LONGER I LAYERED I LIVE ON I
THE MON HI WIRE. HI MELINDA'S NO
MAN. NEWMAN I NIELSEN. A CHARTER
BOAT NO PAM I FOURTEEN TO NO. I
BROUGHT I RUBIO. I SKINNER I
STERN. I I'M BERNARD I WAKE OUT
SKI I WINNER I WILL. NO TOOK
THREE POLICE CALLED OUT TO
MEMBERS. ALAN I ADKINS. PORCHES
THE MEN. NIELSEN NOW. AUGUST
TWENTY NINE KNOWS EIGHT THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW MOVING ON TO
SEND ITS THIRD READING FILE
FIRST UP IS FALL ITEM NINETEEN.
SENATOR SCANNER YOU PREPARED.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE RATE
SENATE RESOLUTION SEVENTY FIVE
BY SENATOR SKINNER RELATIVE TO
WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH. SENATOR
SKINNER FOR YOURS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH- MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS S. R.
SEVENTY FIVE RECOGNIZES MARCH
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AS WOMEN'S
HISTORY MONTH CONGRESS FIRST
ACKNOWLEDGE WOMEN'S HISTORY
MONTH IN MARCH OF NINETEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN. HOW MANY TIMES IN
FLOOR REMARKS AROUND A
RESOLUTION LIKE THIS AND I WILL
REMIND US THAT WE HAVE TAKEN UP
THIS RESOLUTION- EVERY YEAR FOR
MORE THAN A DECADE. THERE IS
OFTEN THE RESEARCH RECITATION.
OF MANY WOMEN THROUGHOUT HISTORY
WOMEN THAT MIGHT EVEN BE
OBSCURED SOME OF US WHO HAVE
ACCOMPLISHED PHENOMENAL THINGS
WHETHER IN INDUSTRY ATHLETICS
INNOVATION THE LAW YOU NAME IT.
BUT I HAVE NEVER LIKED HAVING TO
SPEAK THROUGH. BRING OUT IN
PARTICULAR. FEATS OF WOMEN
BECAUSE IT SEEMS TO ME IT SHOULD
BE OBVIOUS TO ALL OF US. AND IF
WE DO NOT HAVE. FIFTY OR SIXTY
WOMEN IN OUR MINDS THAT WE CAN
IMMEDIATELY BRING TO MIND THAT
HAVE DONE THIS PHENOMENAL THING
SAYS THE FIFTY OR SIXTY MEN THAT
MIGHT COME TO OUR MINDS THEN I
URGE YOU TO DO SO BECAUSE
THEY'RE MORE THAN ABUNDANT. AND
YET THESE THIRTY FIVE YEARS
LATER SINCE CONGRESS DESIGNATED
WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH I NOTICED
WHILE WE HAVE BLACK HISTORY
MONTH SO MANY OTHER HISTORY
MONTHS WE HAVE NO MEN THIS THREE
MONTH. BUT ANYWAY ALL THESE
THREE YEARS THIRTY FIVE YEARS
LATER THE VALUE OF WOMEN IS
STILL OVERLOOKED WOMEN ARE STILL
PAID LESS THAN MEN. EIGHTY THREE
CENTS TO THE DOLLAR AND IF YOU
ARE A WOMAN OF COLOR THAT DOT
THAT AMOUNT DROPS FURTHER. WORK
IS CARE GIVERS WHICH STILL IN
OUR SOCIETY FALLS PRIMARILY TO
WOMEN. GOES UNPAID AND
UNRECOGNISED AND IF THEY ARE
PAID THE WAGES ARE ALWAYS BEHIND
OTHER CATEGORIES OF EMPLOYMENT
AND FALL WELL BEHIND THE RISING
COST OF WOMEN. AND OF COURSE WE
ARE FACING THE CIRCUMSTANCE
WHERE MEN ARE STILL NOT
PROTECTED UNDER THE CONSTITUTION
AGAINST DISCRIMINATION ON THE
BASIS OF SEX. NOW THE
CONSTITUTION REQUIRES THE THIRTY
EIGHT STATES. RATIFY AN
AMENDMENT FOR IT TO BE AN
AMENDMENT OF THE CONSTITUTION.
THE ERA THE EQUAL RIGHTS
AMENDMENT NOW HAS THIRTY EIGHT
STATES WHO HAVE RATIFIED IT. SO
WHY ISN'T IT ALREADY PUBLISHED
IN OUR CONSTITUTION BECAUSE OF
AN ARBITRARY DEADLINE THAT THE
CONGRESS PASSED. THERE'S NOTHING
IN THE CONSTITUTION THAT PUTS A
DEADLINE ON THE RATIFICATION OF
AMENDMENT AND IN FACT THERE'S AT
LEAST ONE AMENDMENT THAT TOOK
OVER TWO HUNDRED YEARS TO RATIFY
. BUT THAT'S FOR ANOTHER DAY.
WOMEN ARE STILL UNDERREPRESENTED
IN BOARD ROOMS. THE EX C. SUITE.
THE ELECTED OFFICE AND INCLUDE
IN INCLUDING IN THIS LEGISLATIVE
BODY. BOTH HOUSES WERE DOING
BETTER BUT WE GOT A LONG WAY TO
GO. AND ALL OF THESE
DISCREPANCIES ARE FAR MORE
GLARING FOR WOMEN OF COLOR. SO
I'M PROUD TO BRING THIS
RESOLUTION FORD AS VICE CHAIR OF
THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS. AND AS WE
USUALLY DO PRE PANDEMIC WE HAVE
OUR FLOOR RECOGNITION OF WOMEN
OF THE YEAR THAT EACH OF THE
MEMBERS RECOGNIZED BUT DUE TO
THE PANDEMIC WE'VE NOT DONE THAT
FOR SOME YEARS. BUT WE KNOW THAT
ALL OF YOU HAVE. I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ORDER A WOMAN IN
YOUR DISTRICT AND HAVE RECEIVED
CERTIFICATES AND SUCH TO PROVIDE
THOSE WOMEN. ALL OF THE SENATE.
LET'S SET OF WOMEN'S CAUCUS
MEMBERS ARE CO AUTHORS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM SENATOR ALSO. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. AS CHAIR OF THE
LATINO CAUCUS IT IS MY HONOR TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SR SEVENTY
FIVE WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH IS
IMPORTANT TO CELEBRATE
EVERYTHING THAT WOMEN HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO OUR COUNTRY IN
OUR SOCIETY. AS TERRIBLE
PRACTICE WHICH HAPPENS TO BE
MAJORITY WOMEN SEVENTEEN
DEMOCRATIC LATINO LEGISLATORS
SEVEN OF US IN THE SENATE I FEEL
IT'S IMPORTANT TO ADDRESS THE
PARTICULAR IMPACT LATINO WOMEN
HAVE ON OUR EVERYDAYLIVES OVER
THIRTY ONE MILLION LATINOS LIVE
IN OUR GREAT COUNTRY 20% OF
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION ARE
LATINA WOMEN AND EACH ONE ADDS
TO OUR AMAZING MOSAIC OF
RESIDENCE. WE ARE CONSUMERS
PARENTS FARM WORKERS AND VOTERS
WE WORK HARD FOR THE AMERICAN
DREAM AND WE STRIVE FOR GREATER
REPRESENTATION AND WE ARE FORCES
OF CHANGE HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE MANY LATINOS WILL BECOME
DISTINGUISHED LEADERS IN THEIR
FIELDS AND CHAMPIONSOF CHANGE
INCLUDING THE LOTUS WHERE THAT.
BUT THE CIGARETTE OUR NEWEST AND
OUR FIRST STATE SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE. THAT BALLOT BLUE GI THE
STATE'S LABOR SECRETARY AND JOAN
BAEZ ARE FAMED RECORDING ARTIST.
NATIONALLY WE LOOK AT THE OTHER
PROUD LET. LIKE JUSTICE SONIA
SOTOMAYOR YOUR ASTRONAUT ELLEN
OCHOA AN ACTRESS THE MORE THAN.
ALL OF WHICH ARE TRAIL BLAZERS
AND THE RESPECT RESPECTIVE
FIELDS AND THEY INSPIRE FUTURE
GENERATIONS OF LATINO LEADERS.
BUT THERE ARE OTHER
INSPIRATIONAL LEADERS WHO ARE
OVERLOOKED ESSENTIAL WORKERS
THEY KEEP OUR ECONOMY RUNNING
DURING THE PANDEMIC. FARM
WORKERS PUT FOOD ON OUR TABLES.
WOMEN ARE THE BACKBONE OF THE
HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY THE LATINO
CAUCUS CELEBRATES MANY OF THESE
CHAMPIONS EACH YEAR NON LATINO
SPIRIT OF WORDS BUT MANY MANY
MORE AND TOO MANY ARE STILL ON
SCENE PLEASE JOIN ME IN
SUPPORTING THIS RESOLUTION
HONORING ALL WOMEN WHO HELPED
WITH THIS EXTRAORDINARY TAPESTRY
WE CALL AMERICA THANK YOU THANK
YOU SENATOR RAZA. CENTER WINNER
. I FIGURE I'M PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY AS VICE
CHAIR OF OUR LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF S. R.
SEVENTY FIVE- WOMEN'S HISTORY
MONTH IS AN IMPORTANT
OPPORTUNITY TO REFLECT ON. AND
HONOR THE ACHIEVEMENTS AND
LEGACIES OF THE MANY GREAT WOMEN
WHO HAVE COME BEFORE US A TIME
TO APPRECIATE THE STRIDES WE
MADE IN ENSURING EQUAL RIGHTS.
FOR WOMEN- AND FOR EVERYONE-
INTO KNOWLEDGE HOW FAR WE STILL
HAVE TO GO- IT'S UNFORTUNATE OF
COURSE THAT THIS YEAR'S
CELEBRATION COMES AT A TIME OF
RISING ATTACKS. ON AGAINST THE
BODILY AUTONOMY AND THE
PERSONHOOD FRANKLY OF WOMEN BOTH
CISGENDER AND TRANSGENDER- THIS
MONTH WE MUST REMIND OURSELVES
OF OUR HISTORY BOTH THE GOOD AND
THE BAD. AND THE WOMEN WHO HAVE
LED AND WHO CONTINUE TO LEAD-
TODAY- AS YOU MAY KNOW IN
ADDITION TO IT BEING ST
PATRICK'S DAY- IS ALSO- A
QUORUM- A JEWISH HOLIDAY- WHERE
WE COMMEMORATES ON A BOLD YOUNG
WOMAN BY THE NAME OF ESTHER- WHO
PLAYED A KEY ROLE IN DELIVERING-
HER PEOPLE THE JEWS. IN PERSIA-
FROM APPLIED TO COMMIT GENOCIDE
AGAINST THEM HER BRAVERY IN THE
FACE OF BOTH CRUELTY AND
INDIFFERENCE IS SIMULTANEOUSLY
EXEMPLARY AND COMMONPLACE.
EVERYDAY WOMEN LIKE ESTHER SERVE
THEIR COMMUNITIES AND PROTECT
THEIR PEOPLE OFTEN WITH NO
RECOGNITION. OF ALL JEWISH WOMEN
HAVE LONG HELD POSITIONS OF
INFLUENCE- IN THEIR OWN
COMMUNITIES THEY'VE ALSO BEEN
CRUCIAL IN THE BROADER FIGHT FOR
WOMEN'S LIBERATION AND EQUALITY
LEADERS LIKE BETTY FOR DAN AND
FELLOW- I'M SUCKING GLORIA
STEINEM. WERE INSTRUMENTAL- IN
THE MOVEMENT OF SECOND WAVE
FEMINISM WHILE LEGAL LUMINARIES
LIKE RUTH BADER GINSBURG AND
BARBARA BOXER AND ELIZABETH
HOLTZMAN HAVE BEEN AND CONTINUE
TO BE TIRELESS VOICES FOR
JUSTICE- WITHIN. OUR GOVERNMENT-
AS WRITERS LIKE YOU'RE MAKING
AND I'M A GOLD REMIND US ON A
BETTER IS POSSIBLE NOT JUST FOR
SOME BUT FOR ALL I'M PROUD. TO
SUPPORT S. R. SEVENTY FIVE AN
URGENT AIBO. THANK YOU CENTER
WINNERS CENTER BRADFORD. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AS CHAIR OF
THE LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS I
JOIN IN SUPPORT AND CELEBRATION.
OF WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH.
CALIFORNIA'S BEEN AT THE
FOREFRONT WHEN IT COMES TO
WOMEN'S RIGHTS AND BLACK WOMEN
HAVE PLAYED AND CONTINUE TO PLAY
A TREMENDOUS ROLE IN THEIR
LEADERSHIP OF THAT MOVEMENT.
BLACK WOMEN IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
BEEN MAKING THEIR MARK IN
PHILANTHROPY. CIVIC LIFE CULTURE
SINCE THE NINETEENTH CENTURY
CAMPAIGNING FOR THE RIGHTS TO
VOTE SUPPORTING AFRICAN
AMERICAN- ARTISTS IN
CONTRIBUTING TO SOCIAL JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN THE HOME OF
MANY BLACK WOMEN PIONEERS. WHO
MADE REMARKABLE ACHIEVEMENTS IN
THIS STATE AND COUNTRY AND- A
MANY OF US ARE LUCKY TO HAVE
BEEN COLLEAGUES WITH- BUT BEFORE
I GET INTO THAT I JUST WANT TO
RECOGNIZE ONE OF THE STATE'S
FIRST. SELF MADE MILLIONAIRES
WAS BETTY MASON- AFTER AMERICAN
WOMAN A LAND OWNER AND IF YOU'VE
EVER GONE THE UNION STATION IN
DOWNTOWN LA ALL THAT PROPERTY
BELONG TO MISS MASON. AND SHE
SOLD IT OR IT WAS STOLEN FROM
HER THE BILL WOULD- UNION
STATION SO SHE WAS ON THE FIRST
LARGE LANDOWNERS TO MILLIONAIRES
BUT- I WANT TO RECOGNIZE SOME OF
THE- HISTORY MAKERS ARE- FIRST
OUR CALIFORNIA FIRST. EVER
SURGEON GENERAL DR NADINE BURKE
HARRIS. A FIRST WOMAN TO CHAIR
THE CONGRESSIONAL BLACK CAUCUS
AND FIRST BLACK MEMBER OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND FIRST
BLACK WOMAN L. ELECTED TO THE
ASSEMBLY- EVONNE BRATHWAITE
BURKE- CALIFORNIA'S FIRST BLOCK.
SECRETARY OF STATE DR SHIRLEY
WEBER THE FIRST BLACK WOMAN AS
SPEAKER NONE OTHER THAN KAREN
BASS. FIRST WOMAN AND FIRST
AFRICAN AMERICAN TO CHAIR THE
HOUSE FINANCIAL SERVICES
COMMITTEE OTHER THAN MAXINE
WATERS FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION OF BLACK
ELECTED THE FIFTH LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN AND MY MENTOR THE LATE WIN
MORE THE FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN
TO CHAIR THE HOUSE
APPROPRIATIONS SUBCOMMITTEE. ON
STATE FOREIGN OPERATIONS AND
RELATED PROGRAMS THE HIGHEST
RANKING AFRICAN AMERICAN IN THE
DEMOCRATIC LEADERSHIP IN THE
ONLY MEMBER OF CONGRESS TO
OPPOSE THE USE OF FORCE AFTER
NINE ELEVEN OTHER THAN BARBARA
AWAY AND THE FIRST WOMAN VICE
PRESIDENT OF THIS COUNTRY
KAMILLA HARRIS THE LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS IS PROUD TO HAVE SO
MANY MEMBERS. OF OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICERS WHO HAVE
MADE AND CONTINUE TO MAKE
HISTORIC ACCOMPLISHMENT FOR
WOMEN WOMEN HISTORY MONTH
PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN
ABOUT THIS STORE GIRL BLACK
WOMEN ACROSS THE STATE AND
NATIONWIDE WHILE WE CELEBRATE
THEIR ACCOMPLISHMENTS WE MUST
ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE THE WORK THAT
STILL NEEDS TO BE DONE IN ENDING
THE VIOLENCE DISCRIMINATION AND
HARASSMENT. OF ALL WOMEN
SPECIALLY BLACK WOMAN IN HELPING
ACHIEVE ECONOMIC AND POLITICAL
EQUITY FOR BLACK WOMEN AS WELL I
ASKED FOR A VOTE THANK YOU THANK
YOU SENATOR BRADFORD SENATOR
AIKMAN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY ON BEHALF THE LGBTQ
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF S. C. R.
SEVENTY FIVE TODAY WE HONOR THE
LIVES CONTRIBUTIONS AND VOICES
OF WOMEN IN OUR NATION'S PAST
PRESENT FUTURE MANY OF WHOM ARE
IN THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY AND HAVE
THAT ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
RIGHTS WE HAVE. TODAY WOMEN HAVE
LED THE MOVEMENT IT WAS A WOMAN
WHO THREW THE FIRST BRICK DURING
THE STONEWALL RIOTS IT WAS A
WOMAN WHO PIONEERED GENDER
AFFIRMING CARE IN THE UNITED
STATES IT WAS A WOMAN IN OUR OWN
CALIFORNIAN BILLIE JEAN KING WHO
SMASHED THE BARRIERS ALLOWING
WOMEN. TO COMPETE AT SPORTS AND
BE ABLE TO HAVE. TAKE CARE OF
THEMSELVES AND NOT LEAST OF ALL
IT HAS BEEN A WOMAN WHO HAS LED
THE SENATE SOME OF THE HARDEST
TIME TO STATE HAS EVER SEEN WELL
KEEPING EQUITY. ANY QUALITY AT
THE FOREFRONT OF OUR WORK THESE
ARE BUT A FEW EXAMPLES OF THE
ROLE WOMEN CONTINUE TO MAKE IN
THE LGBT COMMUNITY. AND IF NOT
FOR THESE TRAILBLAZING WOMEN
MANY OF US ESPECIALLY ME. COULD
NOT STAND HERE BEFORE YOU TODAY
AS A PROUD LESBIAN LATINA. WHO
SERVES MY COMMUNITY EVERY SINGLE
DAY WE IN THE LGBT COMMUNITY-
RETURN THE GRATEFUL TO ALL THE
WOMEN WHO HAVE IT BEEN FOREST TO
LEAD THE WAY AND I RESPECTFULLY
URGE YOUR VOTE. ON S. C. R.
SEVENTY FIVE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
PAT. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT-
SENATORS I TO RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SR SEVENTY FIVE IS
CHAIR OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS-
CERTAINLY AN HONOR TO HAVE STUFF
TO CELEBRATE RECOGNIZE
COURAGEOUS WOMEN THAT SHAPES
CALIFORNIA AND WAS THE DAY IN
OUR NATION. AND I WOULD LIKE TO
POINT OUT THAT- API WOMEN HAVE
NOT ONLY ACCOMPLISHED A LOT BUT
THEY'VE ALSO HAD TREMENDOUS
STRUGGLES AS WELL IN FACT IN
TERMS OF THIS VERY CHAMBER
PASSED LAWS THAT NOT ONLY UP FOR
BID- ASIAN AMERICANS BASICALLY
TRIES AMERICANS FROM COMING TO
THIS COUNTRY- THAT THEY WERE
PHYSICAL LAWS THAT STRICTLY
TARGETED TO PREVENT CHINESE
WOMEN FROM COMING TO THIS
COUNTRY CLASSIFYING THEM
ESSENTIALLY IS- UNDESIRABLE- TO
COME HERE- IN ADDITION- AS WE
ARE UNFORTUNATELY- IN THIS
PANDEMIC EXPERIENCING A WAVE OF
ANTI. ASIAN HATE THE MOST OF
THAT'S ACTUALLY TARGET AGAINST
API WOMEN. IS THE INTERSECTION
ALITY BETWEEN MISOGYNY AND
RACISM THAT HAS CAUSED A P. I.
WOMEN TO BE- PARTICULAR TARGETS
AT THIS TIME. SAME TIME- EIGHTY
I. WOMEN- CONTINUAL CONTINUE TO
COMPETITION AMAZING THINGS FOR
THIS COUNTRY. AND I WOULD LIKE
TO JUST MAKE NOTE CERTAINLY-
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND POLITICAL
ARENA YOU KNOW. THE SECRETARY
STATE MARCH FONG EU IS- WENT
FIRST- I THINK- THROUGH THE
FIRST WOMAN TO BE- SERVING
SECTOR SAY API WOMEN- WE HAVE-
AND THEN OF COURSE- WE CURRENTLY
HAVE TWO CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICERS
WHO ARE A CAT WOMEN I TREASURE
FIANNA MONTREUIL OR BETTY- WE
ALSO OF COURSE HAVE AN R. VICE
PRESIDENTS IN PLACE TO SHARE
WITH THE BLACK CAUCUS- COMELEC
HARRIS WHO ALSO. IS OF ASIAN
DESCENT AS WELL BUT OF COURSE WE
ALSO HAVE WOMEN PLAYING OTHER
ROLES AS WELL IN FACT- JUST MOST
RECENTLY- FOR EXAMPLE OF PIXAR
CAME UP THE FILM TURNING RED
WHICH WAS ACTUALLY LED BY AN ALL
WOMEN TEAM AND- I SEE AGAIN
ILLUSTRATE EVEN THOUGH CANADIAN-
BUT WAS MADE HERE IN SOUTH TEXAS
ARE HERE. IN THE UNITED STATES
AGAIN- LEVIN LEADS AND DIRECTED
THIS OUT WITH THE FIRST WOMAN TO
LEAD AND DIRECT A PIXAR FILM. I
GUESS I'LL JUST ALSO MAKE NOTE
THAT- NOT ONLY FOR THE API
COMMUNITY BUT FOR MANY OTHER
COMMUNITIES TO ACTUALLY TOO
OFTEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT FIRST. KNOWS FIRSTHAND JUST HAPPENED
. THEY'VE JUST TAP. AND THAT
TELLS US HOW MUCH WE HAVE TO GO
SO IT'S GREAT THAT THEY ARE
HAPPENING. BUT IT'S BEEN WAY TOO
LONG. AND SO AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
THE P. I. CAUCUS I WANT TO
THANK. MY GOOD FRIEND- FOR BRING
THIS FORWARD AND AGAIN THAT'S A
WONDERFUL OPPORTUNITY TO
CELEBRATE WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH
BUT WE HAVE SO MUCH FARTHER TO
GO THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
OCULAR. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I
RISE AS A SHARE OF MILITARY AND
VETERANS COMMITTEE ACKNOWLEDGING
THAT WOMEN ON THIS DAY WOMEN'S
HISTORY MONTH WHO SERVE IN OUR
MILITARY ALL BRANCHES OF SERVICE
AND THAT KNOWLEDGE THEIR
ACCOMPLISHMENTS TODAY WE CAN
ACKNOWLEDGE ELEVEN WOMEN WHO
BECOME ARMY RANGERS WHEN THE
MOST DIFFICULT OF POSITIONS IN
THE MILITARY BUT WE HAVE THEY
HAVE THE WOMEN HAVE BROKEN THAT
BARRIER WE'VE GOT TWO SPECIAL
FORCES WOMEN WEST POINT
GRADUATES WHO'VE DONE THE SAME
THING. WOMEN IN THE MILITARY R.
AS IN LEAD OF INFANTRY UNITS
NOW- FLYING HELICOPTERS IN
CHARGE OF TANK UNITS- TAKING
COMMAND NOT ONLY A BRIGADES BUT-
BATTALIONS ALL OVER THE UNITED
STATES MILITARY- WE'VE GOT OF
COURSE OUR ASTRONAUTS WE'VE GOT
LEADERSHIP AT WEST POINT IN ALL
THE ACADEMIES AND WOMEN HAVE
ACTUALLY PAVED THE WAY FOR SO
MANY OTHERS AND THIS DAY IS IT
TRUE THAT THE DAY THAT WE HAVE
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE WOMEN HER
SERVE IN OUR MILITARY. THEY'RE
DOING A GREAT JOB AND I
PERSONALLY CAN TELL YOU THAT I'M
HONORED TO SHARE WITH YOU THAT
MY DAUGHTER IN LAW IS A FELLOW
PARATROOPER HOW ABOUT THAT SHE
WEARS HER WINGS AS I WEAR MINE
AND A WEST POINT GRADUATE AND SO
MANY HAVE DONE SO MUCH AND WHEN
I SERVED WITH THE MONTEBELLO
POLICE DEPARTMENT I HAD THE
HONOR TO SERVE. SIDE BY SIDE
WITH WOMEN IN PARTNERSHIP- AND
THEY WERE THERE READY TO SERVE
READY TO FIGHT READY TO DO
WHATEVER WAS NECESSARY TO SERVE
THE GENERAL PUBLIC WITH HONOR
AND DISTINCTION AND THEY DID IT
IN SUCH A WAY THAT DOORS WERE
OPEN AND KINDNESS AND- IN
HEARTWARMING LOVE IN AND I'M
TELLING YOU THEY ADD SOMETHING
SO VERY SPECIAL TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND ACKNOWLEDGE THEM
AS WELL AND TO THE WOMEN
FIREFIGHTERS. THIS SATURDAY I'M
GOING TO ACKNOWLEDGE WOMEN
FIREFIGHTERS OF LA COUNTY AND-
AT THEIR ACADEMY THAT SHOWS YOU
THAT AGAIN IN WOMEN ARE BREAKING
THAT GLASS. CEILING EVERY SINGLE
DAY IN ALL FORMS OF SERVING OUR
GREATER- CALIFORNIA IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND I URGE AND I VOTE
ON SR SEVENTY FIVE. THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM IN FURTHER
DISCUSSION DEBATE YOUR ENTRY
NINE SENATOR SKINNER WHICH OUGHT
TO CLOSE THANK YOUMR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SO. I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE COMMENTS BY OUR COLLEAGUES
AND AS I REFERENCED IN MY
OPENING I COULD HAVE MENTIONED
MANY MANY MANY WOMEN I COULD
HAVE MENTIONED MANY OF THE WOMEN
IN OUR STATE GOVERNMENT WHETHER
IT WAS OUR FIRST FEMALE SUPREME
A CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE ROSE BIRD. COOL I THINK
HISTORY WILL SHOW WAS MORE
EASILY TARGETED FOR THE RECALL
THAT SHE EXPERIENCED BECAUSE OF
HER GENDER- MARCH FONG EU OUR
FIRST FEMALE SECRETARY OF STATE
ROSANNE RICHER FIRST FEMALE
SENATOR WHO HAD TO GET A
BATHROOM BECAUSE- WE DIDN'T HAVE
THEM FOR WOMEN. BUT LET ME JUST
RECALL A VERY VIVID MEMORY I HAD
WHEN I WAS IN EIGHTH GRADE AND I
WAS ONE OF THE FOUR STUDENT
OFFICERS OF MY CATHOLIC SCHOOL
GOVERNMENT STUDENT GOVERNMENT.
M. I WAS THE SECRETARY I BELIEVE
MY OTHER FRIEND CANDY WAS THE
TREASURER AND THE PRESIDENT. AND
VICE PRESIDENT WERE BOYS. BUT
GIDEON I FOUND OVER THE COURSE
OF OUR YEAR IN STUDENT
GOVERNMENT AS THE OFFICERS THAT
WE WERE DOING ALL THE WORK. SO I
TOLD CANDY I'M A KID. WE GOT TO
GO SEE THE PRINCIPAL SISTER
PATRICIA MARIE AND WE GIVE IT
THIS IS NOT FAIR. PARK OR NOT
THE PRESIDENT THE VICE PRESIDENT
BECAUSE THOSE TWO GUYS GOT TO
STAND AT THE MIKE AT ALL THAT
YOU KNOW WHEN OUR GRADUATION
INTO THE VARIOUS CEREMONIES. WE
WERE IN THE BACK DOING ALL THE
WORK. SOME LIKE LET'S GO TALK TO
SISTER PATRICIA REKINDLING ALL
KNOWN IF YOU KNOW WHAT. WE'RE
GOING. SO CAN I GO SEE PATRICIA
SISTER PATRICIA MARIE GANDHI
ONCE A WORD I SAY SISTER
PATRICIA MARIE. CAN YOU KNOW I
SHOULD BE THE PRESIDENT VICE
PRESIDENT WE'RE DOING ALL THE
WORK. THOSE TWO BOYS THAT'S NOT
FAIR. BASICALLY I DON'T REMEMBER
EXACTLY WHAT SHE SAID BUT IT'S
KIND OF LIKE. GET USED TO IT
WELL I'M SORRY I'M NEVER GOING
TO GET USED TO IT AND I HOPE
THAT AT SOME POINT THE WE WILL
NOT HAVE TO HAVE WOMEN'S HISTORY
MONTH. BECAUSE WE JUST LIKE WE
DON'T HAVE MUCH HISTORY MONTH
NOW THAT PROBABLY WON'T HAPPEN
WHILE I AM STILL SENATORS AND
SOME OF YOU TURNED OUT IN TWO
YEARS. BUT I CERTAINLY HOPE IT
IS STILL WELL I'M BREATHING ON
THIS PLANET AND WITH THAT I ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WELL THE BREED HAS
SEIZED. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON SR SEVENTY FIVE.
ALAN I ARCHULETA HI ATKINS
BASICS I BACKER. I PORCHES
RADFORD HI BYRON EIFERT HAS HE I
DALLY. DALLY I THOUGHT FIVE
YOU'RE AWESOME I EGGMAN FIVE
GLAZER FIVE DOLLARS I GROW. I
HEARD SPURRED BY WEST SO. HI HER
TADO I JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LABOR I THE MON I
REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S I MEN.
BOTH HI PAM I FOURTEEN TINA I
BROUGHT. I RUBIO I SCANNER. I
STERN I AM BERG HI BY CAL SKI I
WINNER I WILL. I I'M SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL UP TO MEMBERS.
ATKINS. PORGES MEN. R. THIRTY
SEVEN KNOWS IT ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES NOW WE'RE MOVING BACK TO
FALL OUT OF LOVE AND SOONER TO
ABOVE ARE YOU PREPARED. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION SEVENTY
NINE BY SENATOR CHILL OF BOTH
RELATIVE TO THE GIRL SCOUTS OF
THE USA. MR BOGLE FLOOR GEORGE.
MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SEVENTY NINE RECOGNIZES MARCH
TWELFTH TWENTY TWENTY TWO AS
NATIONAL GIRL SCOUT DAY. A
HUNDRED AND TEN YEARS AFTER
THEIR INAUGURAL MEETING THE GIRL
SCOUT CONTINUES TO EMPOWER AND
UPLIFT YOUNG WOMEN IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. THE GIRL SCOUT IS
THE LARGEST AND LONGEST RUNNING
AND MOST EFFECTIVE LEADERSHIP
PROGRAM FOR GIRLS NOT ONLY THE
UNITED STATES BUT IN THE WORLD.
WELL WE ALL KNOW OF THEIR ICONIC
COOKIE SALES THE GIRL SCOUTS
HAVE A PROVEN RECORD OF
ENCOURAGING LEADERSHIP SERVICE
AND COMMUNITY ORGANIZATION. GIRL
SCOUT COOKIE SALES TEACH FIVE
SKILLS THAT ARE ESSENTIAL TO
LEADERSHIP TO SUCCESS AND TO
LIVE- SETTING DECISION MAKING
MONEY MANAGEMENT PEOPLE SKILLS
AND BUSINESS ETHICS. GIRLS LOAN
AND LEARNED THAT THERE IS NO
LIMIT TO THEIR SUCCESS AND THAT
ANY GOAL THEY SAID IS ACHIEVABLE
. THE GIRL SCOUTS PLACE A STRONG
EMPHASIS ON HELPING BRIDGE THE
GENDER GAP IN STEM CAREERS BY
OFFERING OVER A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY SIX STEM BADGES INCLUDING
COMPUTER SCIENCE ROBOTICS
CYBERSECURITY. AND ENGINEERING.
SINCE THE FIRST MEETING MORE
THAN FIFTY NINE MILLION GIRLS
HAVE PARTICIPATED IN THE GIRL
SCOUT MOVEMENT AND THAT NUMBER
CONTINUES TO GROW AS GIRL SCOUTS
OF THE USA CONTINUE TO INSPIRE
CHALLENGE AND EMPOWER GIRLS
EVERYWHERE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS TO OFFICIALLY
RECOGNIZE MARCH TWELFTH TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AS NATIONAL GIRL
SCOUT DAY IN CELEBRATION OF THE
SUCCESSES AND CONTRIBUTIONS OF
THE GIRL SCOUTS OF THE USA
ORGANIZATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OF IT
ON THIS ITEM SENATOR PORN TUNE.
I RISE AS THE PROUD FATHER OF
TWO GOLD AWARD GIRL SCOUTS AND A
MEMBER OF THEIR TROOPS TO
STRONGLY SUPPORT S. C. R.
SEVENTY NINE. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OF THE VERY
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OF IT.
THE SOONER A JOB OVER TO LIKE TO
CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER
AND I BOTH. MEMBERS THIS IS
AUDIBLE FOR HUGHES IN A YOU KNOW
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON. FILE
ITEM LEVEL. SENIOR HEARING NONE
ALL EYES THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
SDRS. SEVENTY NINE PASSES NOW
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM. EIGHTEEN
SENATOR COM LAGER SHE'S PREPARED
MADAM SECRETARY MARY SENATE
RESOLUTION SEVENTY FOUR BY
SENATOR CAM WALKER RELATIVE TO
JUSTICE RUTH BADER GINSBURG DAY
. SINNER CALM WATER I THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT THAT- I RISE TODAY
TO PRESENT S. R. SEVENTY FOUR TO
HONOR THE LATE RUTH PATER
GINSBURG AND COMMEMORATE RUTH
PATER GINSBURG DAY ON MARCH
FIFTEENTH. RUTH PATER GINSBURG
ALSO KNOWN AS RBG BY MOST HAS
SERVED AS AN INSPIRATION FOR
GENERATIONS OF PEOPLE ACROSS
THIS NATION FOR DECADES. SHE WAS
BORN JOAN RUTH PATER ON MARCH
FIFTEENTH NINETEEN THIRTY THREE
AND BROOKLYN NEW YORK TO PARENTS
OF UKRAINIAN AND AUSTRIAN
DESCENT. GINSBURG EARNED A
SCHOLARSHIP FROM CORNELL
UNIVERSITY AND GRADUATED FIRST
IN HER CLASS IN NINETEEN FIFTY
FOUR. AND FIFTY SIX GINSBURG WAS
ONE OF NINE WOMEN AND A CLASS OF
MORE THAN FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS
AT HARVARD LAW SCHOOL SHE WAS
THE FIRST WOMAN MEMBER TO JOIN
THE PRESTIGIOUS HARVARD LAW
REVIEW. IN NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT
GINSBURG TRANSFERRED TO COLUMBIA
LAW SCHOOL IN NEW YORK AND WAS
ALSO ELECTED TO THE COLUMBIA LAW
REVIEW AND THEN GRADUATED TIED
FOR FIRST IN NINETEEN FIFTY NINE
IT WAS A BAD MAMA JAMMA. DESPITE
GRADUATING IN THE TOP OF HER
CLASS GINSBURG WAS NOT OFFERED A
JOB BY ANY OF THE FIRMS THAT
INVITED HER FOR INTERVIEW. PRIOR
TO HER TENURE ON THE SUPREME
COURT GINSBURG WAS A FORCE IN
THE LEGAL WORLD AFTER HER TIME
AT BOTH HARVARD AND COLUMBIA LAW%
SHE LANDED A JOB AS A LAW CLERK
FOR THE HONORABLE. ADMIN L. PAUL
MERELY FROM. NINETEEN FIFTY NINE
TO SIXTY ONE AND FROM SIXTY ONE
TO SIXTY THREE HE WAS A RESEARCH
ASSOCIATE AND THEN ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR FOR THE COLUMBIA LAW
SCHOOL PROJECT ON INTERNATIONAL
PROCEDURE. SHE BECAME A LAW
PROFESSOR AT RUTGERS UNIVERSITY
FROM NINETEEN SIXTY THREE TO
SEVENTY TWO AND COLUMBIA LAW
SCHOOL FROM SEVENTY TWO TO
EIGHTY ALL OF THESE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS WERE DONE WHILE
THE LATE JUSTICE FACED EXTREME
GENDER DISCRIMINATION. IN
SEVENTY ONE GINSBURG WORK
CLOSELY WITH THE ACLU TO
ESTABLISH THEIR WOMEN'S RIGHT
PROJECT A PROJECT DEDICATED TO
EMPOWERING WOMEN OF ALL SOCIO
ECONOMIC RACIAL AND ETHNIC
BACKGROUNDS. GINSBURG WAS IN
CALIFORNIA FROM SEVENTY SEVEN TO
SEVENTY EIGHT AS A FELLOW AT THE
CENTER FOR ADVANCED STUDY IN THE
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES AT STANFORD
. IN EIGHTY PRESIDENT CARTER
NAME GINSBURG TO THE U. S.
APPEALS OF THE DISTRICT OF
COLUMBIA. IN NINETY THREE
PRESIDENT CLINTON NOMINATED
GINSBURG TO THE U. S. SUPREME
COURT TO BE AN ASSOCIATE JUSTICE
SHE WAS CONFIRMED AND APPROVED
BY A VOTE OF NINETY SIX TO
THREE. GO FIGURE. GINSBURG WAS
THE SECOND WOMAN AND FIRST
JEWISH WOMAN TO SERVE ON THE
SUPREME COURT IN HER TWENTY
SEVEN YEAR TENURE AS A JUSTICE
GINSBURG DELIVERED POWERFUL
OPINIONS THAT BTH SUPPORTED AND
CHALLENGED HER COLLEAGUES. ON
IMPORTANT MATTERS IN ONE OF HER
MOST POWERFUL OPINIONS DELIVERED
ON UNITED STATES V. VIRGINIA
WHICH CHALLENGED A MEN ONLY
ADMISSIONS POLICY AT THE
VIRGINIA MILITARY INSTITUTE
GINSBURG SAID. SEX
CLASSIFICATIONS MAY BE USED TO
COMPENSATE WOMEN FOR PARTICULAR
ECONOMIC DISABILITIES THEY HAVE
SUFFERED. BUT SUCH
CLASSIFICATIONS MAY NOT BE USED
AS THEY ONCE WERE TO CREATE OR
PERPETUATE THE LEGAL SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC INFERIORITY OF WOMEN.
WOMEN EVERYWHERE HAVE LOOKED TO
RUTH PATER GINSBURG WITH AN
UNDERSTANDING AND APPRECIATION
FOR THE EFFORTS SHE TOOK IN
SUPPORTING OUR RIGHT. HER LEGACY
WILL CONTINUE TO INSPIRE WOMEN
FOR GENERATIONS TO COME IT IS
IMPORTANT AND NECESSARY THAT WE
REMEMBER AND ACKNOWLEDGE
GINSBURG'S WORK AND LIFE FOR
MANY YEARS TO COME. THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS RESOLUTION THANK
YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM SENATOR
HERTZBERG. VERY BRIEFLY- MR
PRESIDENT I JUST WANTED TO ADD.
I THINK SOME OTHER LESSONS OF
RUTH BADER GINSBURG IN HER LIFE.
INFORMAR ADVOCACY. I HAVE HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO MEET WITH HER
WHEN WE GAVE HER A PRIZE. IN THE
NEW YORK PUBLIC LIBRARY AND-
OBSERVE OVER THE YEARS AND WHAT
WAS UNIQUE ABOUT HER. WASN'T
JUST HER EXTRAORDINARY COURAGE
HER KEEN INTELLECT. BUT HER
ABILITY TO DO IT CALMLY AND
QUIETLY AND IN A FEW WORDS.
ANYBODY EVER SHOWN INTERVIEW OR
LISTEN TO HER THE QUESTIONS THAT
YOU'RE ASKING THE SUPREME COURT
. THEY WERE INFUSED WITH RAGING
COMMON SENSE. BASIC DECENCY WHEN
SHE WAS ASKED IN THE FIRST CASE
HE TRIED BEFORE THE SUPREME
COURT DEALING WITH WOMEN'S
RIGHTS AND JUSTICE CHIEF JUSTICE
EARL WARREN ASKED HER A QUESTION
SHE SAID CALMLY I JUST WANT YOU
TO GET. YOUR FOOT OFF OUR NECKS
SHE HAD AN ABILITY THAT WAS
EXTRAORDINARY THERE'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT HAVE DONE GREAT
THINGS IT FOUGHT HARD FIGHTS
WHICH SHE DID IT IN A UNIQUE WAY
AND SHE DID IT IN THE WAY WITH A
PARTNER MARTY HUSBAND. THE
REASON SHE MOVED FROM HARVARD
WHERE SHE WAS FIRST YEAR CLASS.
THE COLUMBIA WAS BECAUSE HER
HUSBAND GOTA- JOBS TAX PARTNER
LAW FIRM. THEY WERE PARTNERS IN
EVERYTHING THEY DID TOGETHER. IF
YOU EVER LEARNED ABOUT THEM AND
KNEW WHAT THEY DID IT WAS THIS
UNBELIEVABLE PERSONAL
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN BOTH OF
THEM THAT RESULTED IN THIS
EXTRAORDINARY SUCCESS NOT OF
THEIR INDIVIDUAL CAREER. BUT ON
THE ISSUES THAT THEY FOUGHT FOR
HE BACKED UP EVERY INCH OF THE
WAY AND IT WAS A GREAT
PARTNERSHIP AND I JUST I JUST
WANTED TO ADD A LITTLE BIT OF
THAT BECAUSE I THINK IT'S WEAK.
OFTEN HONOR PEOPLE. OF THIS
STATURE. THAT IT IS THE DAY
TODAY IT IS THE INTERPERSONAL IS
A SMALL THINGS. IT IS A LESSON
OF HER QUIET CONFIDENCE. THAT
WAS SO POWERFUL. AND FOR THAT I
JOINED IN THIS RESOLUTION I
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT. THANK
YOU SENATOR ALSO. SENATOR DORADO. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I ALSO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION. IN HONOR OF THE
INSPIRING LEGACY AND SERVICE TO
OUR COUNTRY BY JUSTICE RUTH
BADER GINSBURG. HE IS AN EXAMPLE
OF EXTRAORDINARY WORK I'LL BE
FINE WITH THE LEAD BETTER VERSES
GOODYEAR TIRE CASE OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN WHICH INFLUENCED
THE LILLY LEDBETTER FAIR PAY ACT
THAT MADE IT POSSIBLE FOR ALL
EMPLOYEES MEN AND WOMEN TO WIN
PAY DISCRIMINATION. CLAIMS I
ALSO WANT TO MENTION HER
INCREDIBLE IMPACT ON IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES IN THIS NATION HE
HELPED OVERTURN THE ATTEMPT TO
END THE DACA PROGRAM FOR OUR
YOUTH HE VOTED TO- OVERTURN THE
ARIZONA IS B. TEN SEVENTY. WHICH
HAD ALLOWED STATE OFFICERS TO
DETAIN ANYONE THEY SUSPECTED. TO
BE UNDOCUMENTED YOU VOTED IN
FAVOR OF HOLDING THE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS FOR
UNDOCUMENTED MEN AND WOMEN TO
CHALLENGE THEIR DETENTION IN
GOVERNMENT CUSTODY THROUGH ALL
OF HER WORK AND ALL OF HER
EFFORTS JUSTICE GINSBURG
REMINDED US. THAT THE FIGHT FOR
JUSTICE AND EQUALITY IS ONGOING
THIS AND THAT SHE BEST PUT IT
QUOTE A MEANINGFUL LIFE MEANS
LIVING FOR ONE'S FAMILY. AND
ONE'S COMMUNITY NOT FOR ONESELF
AND QUOTE. CHAPELLE SOME OF THE
MOST PRECIOUS FREEDOMS AND
LIBERTIES THAT WE ALL HOLD SO
DEAR AND CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR
EVERY DAY AND I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE TODAY I
ALSO RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT AS A
JOINT AUTHOR OF SR SEVENTY FOUR
WHICH HONORS THE LIFE AND LEGACY
OF JUSTICE RUTH BADER GINSBURG
APPROPRIATE APPROPRIATE BEING
HONORED TODAY ALONG WITH SO MANY
INCREDIBLE TRAILBLAZERS
MENTIONED EARLIER TODAY MARCH
FIFTEENTH IS A DAY TO REMEMBER
AND HONOR RPG FOR BEING A VALUED
FRIEND GUARDIAN OF EQUALITY FOR
ALL I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE ONE OF
MY FAVORITE QUOTES FROM JUSTICE
GINSBURG. PERMISSION TO READ.
PERMISSION GRANTED THANK YOU
WOMEN'S RIGHTS ARE AN ESSENTIAL
PART OF THE OVERALL HUMAN RIGHTS
AGENDA TRAINED ON THE EQUAL
DIGNITY AND ABILITY TO LIVE IN
FREEDOM ALL PEOPLE SHOULD ENJOY
AND AS WE CELEBRATE AGAIN
WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH JUSTICE
PETER GINSBURG JUST ADDS TO THE
LONG LIST OF INCREDIBLE WOMEN
WHOSE SHOULDERS WE STAND ON.
JUSTICE GINSBURG SHAPED AMERICA
LAW FOR DECADES IN THE COURTS
AND HELP PAVE THE WAY FOR CIVIL
AND EQUAL RIGHTS FOR ALL WOMEN
THERE ARE CURRENTLY FORTY
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS AND IT'S BECAUSE
OF PHENOMENAL LEADERS LIKE RPG
THAT GAVE US THE COURAGE TO RUN.
AND FIGHT. NOW WE HAVE THE NEXT
GENERATION OF BRILLIANT MINDS
LIKE STATE ASSOCIATE JUSTICE
PATRICIA GUERRERO WHO WAS
RECENTLY NOMINATED TO SERVE AS
THE FIRST LATINA AND THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT. AND
LAST MONTH HISTORY WAS ALSO MADE
WHEN PRISCILLA CORONADO WAS
ELECTED AS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
HARVARD LAW REVIEW BECOMING THE
FIRST LATINA TO HOLD THIS
PRESTIGIOUS POSITION. THEY ALL
CONTINUE TO ADD TO THE LIST OF
PHENOMENAL WOMEN AND I HOPE IT
CONTINUES. TODAY WE RECOGNIZE
AND HONOR JUSTICE GINSBURG FOR
HER COMMITMENT AND DEDICATION
FOR ALL. AND WE KNOW THAT THE
WORK IS NOT DONE AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO FIGHT BECAUSE OF THE
COURAGE OF ALL THE WOMEN THAT
CAME BEFORE US AND WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN EYEFUL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION INVADE ON THIS ITEM
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM YOU'RE INSANE-
SOONER CAMARGO LIKE CLOSE. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT I JUST WANT TO
THANK MY COMMENT MY COLLEAGUES
FOR THEIR ILLUMINATING COMMENTS
FLESHING OUT THE LIFE AND LEGACY
OF RUTH VADER GINSBERG I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU MEMBERS THIS IS
AUDIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON FILE
ITEM EIGHTEEN SR SEVENTY FOUR.
HEARING SEEING NONE AUGUST
THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS IT ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW MEMBERS WERE
MOVING TO COMMITTEE AND- CONNIFF
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS- WE HAVE
TO. SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT THE ENTRANCE COMMITTEE
WILL CONVENE HALF HOUR FROM THIS
MOMENT HERE IN THE CHAMBERS
THANK YOU. INSURANCE COMMITTEE
WILL CONVENE HERE IN THE CHAMBER
HALF HOUR AFTER SESSION NEXT
SENATOR CAFIERO. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT GOVERN FINANCE
COMMITTEE WILL CONVENE FIFTEEN
MINUTES AFTER ADJOURNMENT IN
THE- STREET BUILDING ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED. SHARE. THE
GOVERNMENT FINANCE COMMITTEE
WILL MEET IN THE OLDS STREET
BUILDING AT. TEN THIRTY THIS
USER. I'M SORRY ONE FIFTY
MINUTES- AFTER GERMAN ART
MEMBERS NOW WE'RE MOVING TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORIES I'M SORRY
SOONER WHEN I'M SORRY I HAVE AN
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT'S NOT A
COMMITTEE NELSON. GOOD GO AHEAD
OKAY THANK YOU- SO THERE ARE AS
A MENTOR FOR TODAY'S TOP FIRMS
AND SO THE JEWISH CAUCUS HAS.
PROVIDED HAMANN TASCHEN WHICH
ARE TRADITIONAL TREAT FOR FIRM
THAT ARE OUTSIDE THE CHAMBERS
AND WE WELCOME EVERYONE TO HAVE
ONE THEY'RE DELICIOUS THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND WE ALSO WANT TO
RECOGNIZE SAME PATRICK'S DAY.
NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY. FIRST UP WE
HAVE MADAM PROTIUM ACTIONS.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT-
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF CIVIC LEADER JAMES
ROBERT DOLL JIM AS HE WAS KNOWN
TO HIS FRIENDS WHO DIED AT THE
AGE OF SEVENTY SIX LAST YEAR.
JIM WAS BORN ON AUGUST TWELFTH
NINETEEN FORTY FIVE IN
CONNECTICUT SPENT HIS EARLY
YEARS THERE BEFORE ATTENDING
LEHIGH UNIVERSITY BECOMING THE
FIRST PERSON IN HIS FAMILY TO
ATTEND COLLEGE AFTER GRADUATING
HE MOVED OUT WEST WHERE HE MET
HIS WIFE MARY THEY WERE MARRIED
IN JULY NINETEEN SEVENTY IN BOTH
WORKED AS TEACHERS IN LOS
ANGELES BEFORE SETTLING IN SAN
DIEGO. JIM GRADUATED FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF SAN DIEGO SCHOOL
OF LAW AND AT THE SAME TIME
ATTAINED A MASTER'S IN CITY
PLANNING FROM SAN DIEGO STATE
UNIVERSITY. TIMMAN MERRY BOUGHT
A HOME IN HILLCREST WHERE THEY
WOULD RAISE THEIR THREE CHILDREN
JEREMY EMILY AND SARAH. WHAT
PRACTICING LAW HE QUICKLY BECAME
RECOGNIZED FOR HIS TALENTS IN
DEALING WITH COMPLICATED LAND
USE MATTERS. THAT REQUIRED
APPEARANCES BEFORE CITY
COUNCILS. THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL COMMISSION.
JIM WAS ALSO DEEPLY PASSIONATE
ABOUT PUBLIC LIBRARIES AND
SERVED AS CHAIR OF THE SAN DIEGO
LIBRARY COMMISSION THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LIBRARY BOARD.
AND THE URBAN LIBRARIES COUNCIL
AND WAS THE FOUNDING CHAIR OF
THE SAN DIEGO PUBLIC LIBRARY
FOUNDATION. HE WAS INTEGRAL TO
CREATING AND HELPING SECURE
FUNDING FOR THE SAN DIEGO
CENTRAL LIBRARY WHICH OPENED IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN. THIS LED TO THE
AFFECTIONATE NICKNAME SO MANY OF
US KNEW JIM BYE TO US HE WAS MR
LIBRARY. AS STRONG AS HIS
DEDICATION TO HIS COMMUNITY WAS
STRONGER STILL WAS HIS DEVOTION
TO HIS FAMILY HE SHARED HIS
PRIDE AND LOVE. FOR FAMILY HIS
FAMILY WITH ANYONE HE MET HE
COACHED ALL THREE OF HIS
CHILDREN AND SOCCER HE WAS QUITE
OFTEN THE LOUDEST PROUDEST VOICE
ON THE SIDELINES. WHICH EARNED
HIM THE OTHER NICKNAME BY QF
MEANING YOUR QUIET FAN WHICH
BECAME A LOVING SON. HE OFTEN
USED WITH HIS CHILDREN FOR THE
REST OF HIS LIFE. LAST SUMMER
JIM WAS DIAGNOSED WITH ADVANCED
GASTRIC CANCER AND HE PASSED
AWAY IN OCTOBER OF LAST YEAR. I
HAVE TO SAY IT WAS THE GREATEST
THING FOR ME TO BE ABLE TO SHARE
WITH HIM THAT IN OUR BUDGET LAST
YEAR WE SECURED FOUR HUNDRED AND
THIRTY NINE MILLION DOLLARS
STATEWIDE. FOR LIBRARIES- IT WAS
IT MADE HIM SMILE. HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE OF FIFTY
ONE YEARS MARY DAUGHTER EMILY
HER HUSBAND DAVID THEIR THREE
CHILDREN OR THEIR CHILDREN JOSH
AND SAMMY DAUGHTER SARAH AND HER
HUSBAND RYAN HIS MOTHER MADELINE
AND A SISTER SHIRLEY AND JANE.
KIM LEAVES BEHIND A LEGACY OF
CIVIC LEADERSHIP KINDNESS AND A
DEEP LOVE FOR HIS FAMILY WE WILL
MISS MR LIBRARY BUT HIS CHAPTER
IN OUR REGION'S HISTORY WILL
LIVE ON FOREVER. COLLEAGUES I
ASK YOU TO JOIN ME IN ADJOURNING
IN MEMORY OF JIM DOYLE. THANK
YOU NORMALLY HAVE TO
CALIFORNIA'S. STATE SENATE WE
OFFER OUR DEEPEST CONDOLENCES
ACID YOU BRING THE NAME FOR IT
SO MR DOS CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED NEXT UP IS SENATOR
UMBERG. MR THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES IT'S WITH
SADNESS THAT ARISE ON A LIFE OF
VERNON MCDONALD WHO PASSED AWAY
AT AGE NINETY SEVEN ON JANUARY
THIRTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
REMEMBER VERNON FOR THE STEAM
SERVICE TO OUR COUNTRY DURING
WORLD WAR TWO HAVING OPERATED IN
BOTH THE EUROPEAN AND PACIFIC
THEATERS A RARE EVENT. WHEN WAS
DRAFTED IN THE US ARMY ON MARCH
TWENTY FIFTH NINETEEN FORTY FOUR
AND COMPLETED BOOT CAMP AT CAMP
CLAIBORNE LOUISIANA FACILITY
THAT EXCLUSIVELY TRAINED AFRICAN
AMERICANS. RUN WAS LEADERSHIP.
OUT TO ELECTRICAL TRAINING
SCHOOL AT NEW YORK UNIVERSITY
CONTINUOUS ARMY EDUCATION. ON
COMPLETION VERNON SERVED IN ALL
BLACK. ONE THREE TWO ONE
ENGINEER GENERAL SERVICES
REGIMENT TO CONSTRUCT ROADS
BRIDGES REPAIR AIRFIELDS
MAINTAIN ELECTRICAL EQUIPMENT
SUPPORT FOR OPERATIONS AND
CIVILIAN RECONSTRUCTION HE
SERVED UNDER THE THIRD AND
SEVENTH ARMY AS AN ASSISTANT
GENERAL PATTON'S THIRD ARMY IN
THE DASH FOR THE RHINE LET.
BURNHAM WASN'T TRANSFERRED TO
THE PACIFIC WHICH WAS A RARE
EVENT TO HAVE A SOLDIER SERVING
BOTH THE- NEWS WHERE HE SERVED
IN OKINAWA WITH THE BUFFALO
SOLDIERS FROM THE TWENTY FOURTH
INFANTRY REGIMENT. AND MOVED ON
FROM THE- RIKON YOU ISLANDS TO
THE PENINSULA OF KOREA AFTER TWO
YEARS OF SERVICE VERNON HAVE
BEEN PROMOTED TO MASTER
SERGEANT. AND RECEIVED HIS
HONORABLE DISCHARGE ON APRIL
THIRTIETH NINETEEN FORTY SIX.
BURNER WILL BE REMEMBERED BY HIS
WIFE READ OF SIXTY SEVEN YEARS
IS THREE CHILDREN BOBBY VERDA
MCDONALD LINDA IS WIFE LINDA
WILLIAM MARK MCDONNELL'S WIFE.
MELANIE AND ELAINE REGINA
MCDONNELL NEARLY. AND HER
HUSBAND OIL AND SIX
GRANDCHILDREN TWELVE GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN- I DID NOT KNOW
VERNON BUT HE MUST'VE BEN A
GREAT MAN BECAUSE I KNOW HIS SON
BOBBY WHO IS A GREAT MAN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CENTER AMBER.
THANK YOU SENATOR UMBERG SENATOR
BRADFORD. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT PRESIDENT AND I JOINED
AND KNOW WHICH CENTER ON BERGEN
ADJOURNING IN MEMORY OF VERNON
MYERS. MCDONALD AS STATED PASSED
AWAY AT THE AGE OF NINETY SEVEN
HE WAS BORN ON JUNE FOURTH
NINETEEN TWENTY FOUR. AND SOUTH
SIDE OF CHICAGO. BUT WAS RAISED
IN LOS ANGELES. I WAS RAISED BY
HIS MOTHER THERESA HARDEN AND
HIS STEPFATHER ROBERT ZIEGLER
HARDEN- RUN WAS DRAFTED IN THE
U. S. ARMY ON MARCH TWELFTH
TWENTY FIFTH NINETEEN FORTY FOUR
AND SERVE. THE COUNTRY BRAVELY
DURING WORLD WAR TWO. HE MARRIED
RITA MARY VOLVO STORE ON
DECEMBER TWENTY FIRST NINETEEN
FORTY FOUR AND IS PRECEDED IN
DEATH BY HER. HIS OLDER BROTHER
FRANKLIN MCDONALD AND SISTER
MARNIE MARIE HARDEN. VERNON RITA
WERE MARRIED FOR SIXTY SEVEN
YEARS AND THEY HAVE THREE
CHILDREN AS STATED MY GOOD
FRIEND BOBBY HIS BROTHER WILLIAM
AND HIS SISTER- ALAIN. AFTER THE
WAR WERNER FURTHER HIS EDUCATION
TO BECOME AN ELECTRICIAN AND WAS
A CAREER LONG MEMBER OF THE
INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS UNION- HE WAS
THE SECOND BLACK MEMBER. OF HIS
LOCAL CHAPTER ANY MAINTAIN
MEMBERSHIP FOR SEVENTY TWO YEARS
AS A SENIOR LECTURERS IN VERNON
HELPED BUILD THE MARTIN LUTHER
KING COMMUNITY HOSPITAL IN MY
DISTRICT AND LATER WARM FOR THE
BROADCAST BOOTH FOR THE NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR. OLYMPICS IN LOS
ANGELES HE ALSO CONTRIBUTE TO
CIVIC ORGANIZATION AND WAS A
BOARD MEMBER OF A BLACK OWNED
BANK ENTERPRISE SAVINGS AND LOAN
IN COMPTON CALIFORNIA. VERNON
EARNED A SILVER BEAVER AWARD
FROM THE BOY SCOUTS OF AMERICA
FOR HIS DEDICATION TO THAT
ORGANIZATION AND THOUGH HE WAS
NEVER A SCOUT AND THAT'S
COMMENDABLE IN AND OF ITSELF. HE
WILL BE REMEMBERED FOR HIS
PLEASING PERSONALITY AND WARM
DISPOSITION AND HIS LEGACY WILL
BE CARRIED ON THROUGH HIS
CHILDREN HIS GRANDCHILDREN AND
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN MEMBERS
PLEASE JOIN ME IN. A JOURNEY TO
MEMORY OF RUNNING BCK DONNEL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD. NEXT INTERNAL MEMORY
IS SENATOR LEYVA.
SINNER LABEL WILL BE DOING HER
JOURNEY MEMORY WHEN READY. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS IT IS
WITH GREAT SADNESS THAT I ASKED
THAT WE ADJOURNED TODAY IN THE
MEMORY OF CAPTAIN WALTER GREEN
BRATTON WHO PASSED AWAY ON
FEBRUARY THIRTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. A DEVOTED HUSBAND
FATHER GRANDFATHER SON BROTHER
UNCLE COUSIN FRIEND NEIGHBOR
DEACON AND FIREFIGHTER WALTER
BRATTAIN WAS BORN ON NOVEMBER
THIRD NINETEEN FIFTY ONE IN ROCK
HILL SOUTH CAROLINA. IN JUNE
NINETEEN FIFTY SIX THE FAMILY
MOVED TO ONTARIO CALIFORNIA
WHRE WALTER WAS FOUR YEARS OLD
AND HIS PARENTS IMMEDIATELY
JOINED THE MOUNT ZION BAPTIST
FAMILY CHURCH WALTERS CHRISTIAN
FAITH WAS COURT TO HIS IDENTITY.
AND HE WAS AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF
MOUNT ZION UNTIL HIS PASSING.
GROWING UP IN ONTARIO WALTER
ATTENDED ONTARIO SCHOOLS HE
ATTENDED TV HIGH SCHOOL AND WAS
ALSO PART OF THE SECOND
GRADUATING CLASS OF ONTARIO HIGH
SCHOOL THE CLASS OF NINETEEN
SEVENTY. AFTER GRADUATING HIGH
SCHOOL WALTER ATTENDED CHAFEE
COLLEGE WHERE HE CONTINUED TO
PLAY FOOTBALL AND ALSO EARNED
HIS AA DEGREE. ON FEBRUARY
SECOND NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE
WALTER BRATTON BECAME THE FIRST
AFRICAN AMERICAN FIRE FIRE HIRED
BY THE ONTARIO FIRE DEPARTMENT.
WHEN WALTER AND MARILYN MARRIED
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE AND
THEY HAVE SIX CHILDREN MARLEN
MARCUS WALTER AARON MARLIN. AND
ASHLEY ON AUGUST FOURTEENTH
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT WALTER WAS
PROMOTED BECOMING THE FIRST%
AFRICAN AMERICAN FIRE CAPTAIN
FOR THE CITY OF ONTARIO.
ALTHOUGH HE PASSED THE TEST TO
BE PROMOTED TO BATTALION CHIEF A
FEW YEARS LATER A BATTALION
CHIEF BACON C. NEVER OPENED
BEFORE HIS EXAM RESULTS EXPIRED.
AFTER THIRTY ONE YEARS WITH THE
ONTARIO FIRE DEPARTMENT CAPTAIN
WALTER G. BATON BRATTON RETIRED
ON DECEMBER TWENTY THIRD TWO
THOUSAND SIX TAKING HIS LAST
RIDE WITH FULL SALUTE AND HONOR
FROM HIS FIRE STATION SIX IN JIM
CROW. FOLLOWING HIS RETIREMENT
WALTER VOLUNTARILY SERVED
ANOTHER FIFTEEN YEARS AS A
CHAPLAIN FOR THE ONTARIO FIRE
DEPARTMENT. WALTER WAS DIAGNOSED
WITH ALS IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN WHICH TOOK HIS VOICE
AND LIMITED HIS MOBILITY BUT NOT
HIS WILL OR HIS SENSE OF HUMOR.
AND HE TRULY FOUGHT THE GOOD
FIGHT AGAINST THIS DISEASE. IN
THE SUMMER OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WALTER WAS RECOGNIZED BY THE
CITY OF ONTARIO AS A COMMUNITY
HERO. BEFORE HIS PASSING
WALTER'S CHILDREN ESTABLISH THE
CAPTAIN WALTER G. BRETON
FOUNDATION. AS THE LEADER
VISIONARY AND EMERGENCY FIRST
RESPONDER WITH A HEART OF GOLD
WALTER HIMSELF PICKED HIS
FOUNDATION'S LOGO AND FOUNDATION
MID MISSION OF GIVING BACK TO
LOCAL YOUTH AND FAMILIES IN NEED
IN THE ONTARIO COMMUNITY HE
SERVED HIS ENTIRE LIFE. HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE THREE
SISTERS SIX CHILDREN AND MANY
GRANDCHILDREN SOME MEMBERS
PLEASE JOIN ME IN ADJOURNING
TODAY IN THE MEMORY MEMORY OF
WALTER G. BRATTON. THANK YOU
SENATOR LEVIN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE WE OFFER
OUR CONDOLENCES ASSET YOU BRING
THE NAME FOR IT SO YOU CAN BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED. NEXT UP
IS SENATOR CALM WATER. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT TODAY I RISE TO A
TURN IN THE MEMORY OF JACQUELYN
JACKIE WHITE WHO PASSED AWAY ON
JANUARY EIGHTH. TWENTY TWENTY
TWO SHE WAS SEVENTY SIX YEARS
OLD. JACKIE WAS BORN IN PINE
BLUFF ARKANSAS ON MAY TWENTY
SECOND NINETEEN FORTY FIVE AND
WAS THE OLDEST CHILD OF THE LATE
JUNE MOON AND MARY ELLEN JOHNSON
. JACKIE GREW UP AND ATTENDED
SCHOOLS IN MEMPHIS TENNESSEE.
AFTER GRADUATING HIGH SCHOOL SHE
ATTENDED MEMPHIS STATE
UNIVERSITY FROM NINETEEN SIXTY
TWO TO SIXTY SIX. JACKIE MET
ADMIN L. WHITE JUNIOR IN COLLEGE
AND THEY MARRIED IN NINETEEN
SIXTY SIX THEY HAD THREE
CHILDREN IN MEMPHIS BEFORE
MOVING TO CHICAGO IN NINETEEN
SIXTY SEVEN. IN CALIFORNIA IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY. JACKIE ENJOYED
READING AND HER FAVORITE POET
WAS NIKKI GIOVANNI. JACKIE ALSO
ENJOYED ARTWORK CRAFTS WOMEN'S
STUDIES DANCING AND SPENDING
TIME WITH FAMILY AND FRIENDS.
JACKIE WHITE WORKED IN THE
UNITED STATES POSTAL SERVICE FOR
OVER FORTY YEARS SHE WAS A
MEMBER OF THE LOS ANGELES BRANCH
TWENTY FOUR OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF LETTER CARRIERS
JACKIE SERVED IN THE UNION IN
VARIOUS POSITIONS AT THE LOCAL
STATE AND NATIONAL LEVEL. IN
ADDITION TO DELIVERING MAIL
JACKIE TAUGHT LABOR STUDIES
COURSES AT THE LOS ANGELES TRADE
TECH COLLEGE IN THE THIRTIETH
DISTRICT FOR OVER TWENTY FIVE
YEARS. JACKIE PASSED PEACEFULLY
SURROUNDED BY HER FAMILY AT
SAINT JOSEPH'S HOSPITAL ON
JANUARY EIGHT TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
JACKIE IS SURVIVED BY HER TWO
LOVELY DAUGHTERS ANGELA WHITE
AND PAMELA BELL FOUR
GRANDCHILDREN BRIANNA BALLY MARI
BELL CHEYENNE BELEN PARKER
WHITE. AND THREE GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN I AM ON A COB
CHRISTOPHERCOBB AND STEPHANIE
ROBERTS SHE LOST HER SON STEPHEN
WHITE IN TWENTY NINETEEN JACKIE
ALSO LEAVES A HOST OF NIECES
NEPHEWS COUSINS GOD CHILDREN AND
ME IN A TURNING IN THE MEMORY OF
MISS JACKIE MAY MOVE WHITE THANK
YOU. THE GENERAL NUMBER OF
SENATORS. HOME BLOGGER HANNAH AS
THAT YOU BRING THE NAME FORD SO
MISS WHITE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED. IF THERE'S NO
OTHER BUSINESS INTERACTION
SUGGESTS IS CLEAR. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT AND I
HAPPY ST PATRICK'S DAY TO ALL
OUR NEXT FLOOR SESSION IS
SCHEDULED FOR MONDAY MARCH
TWENTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO
AT TWO PM THANK YOU. MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL THREE THIRTY AT WHICH TIME
AN ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
MADE WILL RECONVENE ON MONDAY.
AT TWO THIRTY PM THANK YOU. TWO
TWO PM.